So, for the longest time, I thought that
the closest thing to a solution for a
tuck turn in split time, same direction
would be this, where we switch back and
forth between a windmill and a
watermill. There's just one problem. I
enter my windmills going clockwise with
my left hand tucking behind first, and I
enter my watermills going clockwise with
my right hand tucking behind first. As
you might be able to see here, this
means that I have to add an extra half a
beat on either side in order to complete
the move, which turns this into a three
pedal in spin rather than a two pedal in
spin. And then I connected some dots.
So, you remember our split time opposite
stuck turns and how much they looked
like our snakes in split time opposites?
Well, many of us when we're first
learning how to do snakes are trying to
learn how to do these snakes right here.
When we're spinning the poi in split
time, same direction. And guess what? If
the split time opposites snakes feel a
lot like tuck turns, the split time same
direction snakes kind of do as well.
There's all the essentials there. We're
moving our hands both up and down as
well as side to side. And we're tucking
the PO behind our shoulder and up behind
our armpit as we go back and forth. The
biggest thing is we don't really have a
lot of latitude in bringing our hands up
and down. I can kind of exaggerate this
a little bit. And hey, would you look at
that?